wills tremendous he's he's uh he's he is
a movie star in the old model you know
as you know and and and a really really
great actor he's terrific in this film
it's a very very moving performance not
not just a entertaining one and he's the
only you know he he he pulls up in Soho
and he he puts this trailer up that's
like about three stories below Trump
Tower it's like it if you have a fifth
floor loft in Soho wit you're looking
into wills trip that's his trailer I can
drive around anyway right right and and
if I if you were me did that like
there'd be a riot and and and with him
it turns into a block party
everybody's happy that you know right he
leaves he net he leaves people happy in
his wake it's amazing I'm gonna cancel
my order for a five story trailer I've
long told Andy that's all I want is a
five super Network already canceled they
killed it they killed it it's not
happening I want to bring up something
well first of all I heard that you and
will had a kind of a connection over the
show Hamilton is that right yes I mean
everyone's upset like everybody yeah i i
i can probably often be seen wandering
around in the village at midnight like
walking my dog you know with it and i
think there's been a few NYU students
going is that is that Edward Norton like
singing the lines to Hamilton like while
wearing like a new sane bolt hat and
they're like what happened to that guy
yeah yeah I used to be so easy to be so
I have so much cred yeah yeah so I love
it and will loved it well loves it yeah
we'll loved it and we we the that's the
set of this film collateral Beauty it
was it was a it's an emotional film it
has a lot of um it has a lot of heavy
stuff in it and it was it was often
leavened by by will and I kind of rap
battling Hamilton lyrics across oh in
between on stage in between so that's
yes that's a nice tension did you ever
like sometimes I know Mike I am NOT
being asked to come fill in I will not I
will not be like maybe after John Stamos
yeah
Stamos is doing it now yeah this is
doing it now they're actually getting
the whole cast of that show back
together
you